bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono qua vj ed oggi
siamo tornati su perché è un'imposizione
come stessi facendo la carica ai ragazzi
direi di cominciare subito prima che
succeda al disastro nelle mie intro
secolari come sempre ma voi ragazzi ve
lo avevo promesso nello scorso episodio
perché da allora me l'avete chiesto
tutti quindi non possono mantenere la
mia promessa e lo faccio poi con centro
e merda sarà un disastro ma lo faccio
col senso perché non avete chiesto
diciamo soltanto che ballare canzoni dpa
sai non è il mio forte ma ci provo
ugualmente mai cosa possiamo fare
iniziare ha centrato il punto ci ho
messo mezz'ora
ok dato anche il caffè
ok non lo sapevo mettiamo prima ok per
vecchi sono l'inizio è perfetto maicon a
galla
ma
[Musica]
ma e colonia
all
cari finance day
ragazzi non solo anche del cazzo sta
dicendo ormai questo sia lei ha più
parlato di facendo far succedere di
nuovo
e noi cosa che non posso sopportare ma
lo faccio per voi ha mai fatto faville a
maggio phan fah bj a lui è un tiro è
iniziata la sua puntata rega ma qualcuno
fa decifrare il testo della canzone che
si capisce un cazzo
sì va bene a napoli mapperà veramente io
sono stanco morto ma non voglio farlo
vedere a maggio foto quadri gente ama la
gasco ponendo come chiuse di 11 a me due
pari e 3 kg
[Musica]
mai e poi mai per caso trova che io stia
veramente figo così mi sento troppo il
gioco
il pubblico
[Musica]
chi è che ha preso tre stelle chi è che
ho preso tre stelle ragazzi senza
contare gli stessi 6 nel punteggio
sono un [ __ ] pro ragazzino qualcosa
di più tranquillo e si spera perché io
sono già morto
c'è una cosa in effetti ragazzi l'ho
trovato modo con questo perché sono mi
ammazzo sono già stanchissimo ragazze un
questo fatto subito
si accettano scommesse 5 stelle mai
successo
la partenza è sexy quindi direi che ci
siamo sulle vari ragazzi sulle mani per
poni j
già possiamo fare 5 stelle sto partendo
già di merda ma non importa
mi piace salazar megli siamo mi mette
tranquillità una canzone dove non devo
tirare fuori i polmoni
ovviamente ragazze non c'è pitbull non
c'è storia
sì la versa da sempre in tutte le sue
tutte canzoni
[Musica]
gatto sto facendo
mio dio la cosa non si fa per cinque
potute belle
[Musica]
ha già qua ma non c'era avrà sbagliato
su 7 allora signorina gilera se faccio
lo stesso mou scorso che fece a jennifer
lopez è inutile che tenta di essere più
sexy di me perché tanto non ci riesce
ragazzi sto morendo basta facciamo più
come si cresce si sono veramente lei
pensa di essere più sexy di me il mio
giro vita molto meglio ragazzi che la
sta facendo ragazzo rom 8 basta vi prego
l'altro caso dobbiamo continuare così
papà ti sei impazzita che cazzo sta
facendo
miu miu ho visto tutta la pizza è finita
e mi dice ho preso due stelle ma su tre
non su cinque operai che non me ne frega
un cazzo
basta che lo finita perché devo portarmi
esageratamente sul letto anche se va via
live viene mai la luce il cazzo vero
tolto chi che ti perdi sappia quello che
fa perché lo sa che un po dj stanco non
è non è tanto gentile ma io ci provo lo
stesso la cosa fantastica anche voi che
siamo partiti benissimo almeno quello
[Musica]
no mai
questo ragazzi classico caso io la
vedevo l'ora di poterlo ballare mai caso
messo anche smettere
in ogni caso di the zombie
robson life jacket è stato pescato ilike
ho preso non ci posso credere non ci può
succedere grande chietti maicon si
macchiano giusto allora sono la terza
stella
anche l'ultima canzone capito mischiamo
riuscirci ragazzi accettano scommesse
scrivete nei commenti se pensate che c'e
la forza 4 nov
io sinceramente scriverei no ma ci provo
anche il peso
insomma
io
dai ragazzi
lo zio tutto racchiuso assurda va beh
almeno tre stelle non freighter che si
portano le quattro ragazzi concludo che
l'episodio perché sono stanco morto
arrivo anche sapere le canzoni che
volete che io parli nel prossimo
episodio ovviamente non voglio
condizionarvi a tutto mezzo nel voto
comunque ragazzi se vi è piaciuto
come al solito lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
della generazione scritti iscrivetevi
indici di vediamo il prossimo video dai
ragazzi